- Hup!
- Hup?
Is that your name?
- Mm-hmm, Hup!
Ha!
Ah?
Ooh, ha ha!
(humming)
At ha roar!
Hup.
(laughs)
- That stone in the wood.
(blows raspberry)
- Move podling.
- The Gelfling here are all so different.
- Yeah, rude.
- Watch out.
- Look at that ladder!
I wonder where it goes.
- [Hup] Hmm.
- Oh, hi!
- Huh?
- Hello!
- Deet, Hup not welcome or to be.
Bleh!
- Stop it, Hup.
They're just curious.
- Sail at your command
(blows raspberry)
- Hmm
- I don't like him either.
- Huh.
- Come on, Hup. It'll be fun!
- [Podling Language]
Hup...
want...
die!
- Aww
(vomits)
(sighs)
(sings in Podling)
(bang)
- Quiet, podling!
- Huh?
- You'll give everyone nightmares
with that wailing.
- Hmph.
- Ha! That ought to do it.
(sings loudly)
(sighs)
- Podlings...
- Thank you, wise paladin.
(kisses)
- Oh!
(laughs)
- Agh!
We go! We go!
- Where did you get all that?
- Ha!
Mwah! (Podling)
- Oh! Um...
How do I look?
- Deet always beautiful.
(Podling)
- Uh, (Podling)
- Not now, Hup!
- Is this podling in his right mind?
- He wants to be a paladin.
- No time for ceremony now, podling.
Innocent lives are at risk.
Stand and prove the strength of your spoon
by my side.
- (Podling)
Hup!
(squirts)
- Whoa!
Disaster!
(screeches)
(Podling Language)
(thuds)
Whoa!
(groans in pain)
- There's no place in
Thra you can hide from me!
- No! No!
- No...
Hurt...
Deet!
- Ah!
(laughter)
What?
(screams)
Hup! Watch out!
(grunts and scuffles)
- Oh, and bring your podling slave.
- He's not our slave! He's our friend.
- Should run. SkekSis (Podling)
Crazy!
- Oh, and we'll need to borrow
your friend's slave.
- Huh?
(angry muttering)
- Wonderful
- In honor of Gelfling...
- [Skeksis] Louder!
- [Heretic] More wonder!
- In honor of Gelfling!
- Gah! Nevermind!
[Heretic] Gah! That's enough.
Thank you, thank you.
- Hm!
Hm!
Hm! Hm!